München ist auch im Winter eine ziemlich
freundliche und einladende Stadt.
Und die Gelegenheit,
Marienplatz, Frauenkirche
und Münchener Lebensart kennenzulernen,
solltet ihr euch nicht entgehen lassen.
Und wenn‘s geschneit hat, findet
ihr sogar Gelegenheiten für Wintersport.
Im „Englischen Garten“ etwa
könnt ihr rodeln
oder es den Eisbach-Surfern gleichtun.
Der Winter eignet sich
natürlich auch für Museumsbesuche.
Die wichtigsten Häuser findet
ihr alle im Museumsviertel,
dem sogenannten „Kunstareal“.
In der „Alten Pinakothek“ etwa könnt ihr in
die europäische Kunstgeschichte eintauchen.
Schon die bayerischen Könige aus dem
Haus Wittelsbach haben gerne gesammelt
– alles, was Rang und Namen hat:
von Albrecht Dürer bis zu
Peter Paul Rubens.
Die „Alte Pinakothek“ spielt da in
der wirklichen Oberliga mit,
gehört zu den berühmtesten
Galerien der Welt,
eben dank der Sammelleidenschaft der
früheren Generationen der Wittelsbacher.
Das Kontrastprogramm findet ihr
gleich nebenan im Museum Brandhorst.
Einige Werke von
Andy Warhol zeigen es:
In der Sammlung des
Stifterehepaars Brandhorst
geht es vor allem um die
Kunst des 20. Jahrhunderts.
Von daher ist es natürlich ’n ganz, ganz
toller Punkt, weil man einfach Menschen,
die mit Gegenwartskunst nicht
so viel zu tun hat [haben],
auch ’n super Einstieg bieten kann.
Jeder kennt Warhol, aber man kann …hat
eben auch die Möglichkeit, [das] zu vertiefen,
und dann in andere
Sphären mal zu leiten
und und auf andere
Künstler auch hinzuweisen.
Und wenn ihr nach dem Museumsbesuch
eine Stärkung braucht,
dann ist es vielleicht
Zeit für das Hofbräuhaus.
Eine Münchener Institution
seit über 425 Jahren.
Unser Reiseführer sagt:
Das muss man gesehen haben.
Toll, dass alle so gut drauf sind.
Auch wenn es bei dem Besucheransturm
vielleicht gar nicht so aussieht,
hier findet ihr meist noch einen Platz.
Im Hofbräuhaus können 1300
Gäste bewirtet werden.